hello my name is Jo Ann Jackson I'm a
professor at the Rochester Institute of
Technology joint appointment on school
of interactive games and media and the
school of mathematical sciences my
presentation today is called the
Caribbean trapezoid it's a sci-fi mixed
reality platform for teaching
computational thinking
so to start off with just an overview
I'll be giving a background and the
motivation for the project and then
we'll get into a little bit of the story
and take a look at some of the resources
that have been developed here in order
to use this as part of a course an
introductory course in computational
thinking so the background here actually
goes back a couple of years ago when I
first learned about the possibility of a
Unity link coming out and I got very
excited about it because of this fact
that I'm in the school of interactive
games and media and the school of
mathematical sciences I thought it would
be great to use Mathematica and the
Wolfram language in some of the math
courses that I'm teaching and then have
something like Unity game engine to be
able to let students see how the
mathematical concepts that they're
learning about vectors and
transformations how those could actually
be used in in some fun ways and some
some interesting ways but also
simulating sort of the real world so I
I've been working on some combinations
of exercise games and music games and I
had something that I developed called
the syncopated surfing ring you can sort
of still see a little bit of that here
with these these those are surfboards
around the peripheral here then as it
turned out I had been collecting k-cups
these non-recyclable capsules that and I
started to think about what use I could
put those to and I had been putting
together a large string of them to use
to demonstrate the idea of Bezier curves
and then as it turned out I kept
collecting more and more and more and
I've got way too many of them so then I
had to think of something else to use it
for so this idea of creating a little
model of a sailboat which I called riff
raft came to me and
then this whole idea of the unity link I
thought well we could make some I could
make something like a surfing or rather
sailing simulation and actually I see
Todd Gale he's here so a year ago he
gave a talk where he showed how he had
equipped his own sailboat with all kinds
of sensing gear and being able to
capture that data and optimize sail
settings and headings and so forth so I
got very interested in the use of the
same kind of technology here so my
original plan was just to try to use
something like this to demonstrate of
course the ideas of vectors and forces
so that's sort of where things started
but then then I had the opportunity to
create a course for freshmen in science
majors and I thought what better way to
start them off in programming but to use
Wolfram language and so then I started
to think how could I take this this
whole far-fetched scheme involving
riffraff and so forth and incorporate
that into all these other kind of
desired types of considerations that I
wanted to take into account and in this
course so let me just try to read a few
of these to you I see that the font is
maybe a little bit too small so maybe
it'll help if I read these so I wanted
to have some innovative alternative to
the AP computer science principles type
course and so one of the things I wanted
to do of course was use Wolfram language
here but also I wanted it to be that one
of the advantages of Wolfram language as
everyone here presumably knows but it's
it's deep enough to provide a really
strong basis upon which then they can
later build extensively on their own so
these are non computer science majors
taking lots of other courses so they
don't have a lot of time to take other
programming courses necessarily but yet
as they can start taking advantage
immediately of what they've learned with
the Wolfram language
and there's plenty of resources out
there for them to learn more
independently and as as the need arises
while they're taking courses in their
second third and fourth year I also
thought I wanted to be able to have
something that allowed them to
immediately start taking advantage of of
what they've learned and in their
subsequent college courses of course
math courses and physics courses are
obvious examples but also biology
chemistry what-have-you
I wanted to prepare students to pursue
you know numerous diverse and newly
emerging career options as as if you've
read Stephen Wolfram's blog you probably
recognize this quote where he says about
computational thinking pick any field X
there's either now or soon will be a
computational X and so I think very
strongly that we need to be preparing
our students for the types of careers
that we can't even imagine right now
exist I know when I was studying
mathematics and computing early on I
hadn't imagined that I would ultimately
end up in a in a game design and
development degree program teaching that
so of course motivation is important and
engaging science students by performing
letting them perform computational
experiments and making interactive
simulations and visualizations I think
that's a real strength of the Wolfram
language and then when we combine that
with with using unity link to have the
Unity game engine that gets even more
offers even more possibilities I think
it's it's really important we in the
game design and development school we
have many group projects that our
students work on and I see the benefit
of them being able to start working in
teams and taking advantage of all their
different strengths from from various
backgrounds so developing group
problem-solving skills was another
important consideration and then letting
them be creative building original works
that they can share with others
both to teach and just be excited about
let's say giving performances live
coding exhibitions even things like
eSports to incorporate all these
different elements of exercise
entertainment enlightenment pretty much
anything that starts with an E I suppose
combining that with educational
opportunities providing experiences that
are analogous to what they get by being
what's a members and music ensembles
sports teams math computer programming
science clubs theatrical and dance
troupes I guess I didn't include here
like a debate team but that figure out
some way to incorporate that as well
then lastly I think providing experience
with being site in the field of science
you know you you don't just read things
off a thermometer anymore you've got
digital devices and the connected
devices capability Wolfram language is
is extremely important here they they
can capture and process sensory data
from cameras microphones accelerometers
and then also I think being able to use
machine learning that's an exciting
prospect that in most introductory
programming classes you'd never be able
to get quite that far that you're
actually incorporating state of the art
machine learning and that and then
lastly again in reference to Stephen
Wolfram I really liked the idea of
computational essay as something that
students can can be involved in in
writing themselves and so forth so I
wanted to further stretch that notion to
include what I considered a
computational sci-fi tale where they're
doing some creative science fiction
writing but it's not so far from the
truth or reality that it's that it's
useless and the idea then that you could
act have a Unity game engine be like
these pop-up books right where something
suddenly comes to life and they can
create a simulation of a sit of a
situation I
those are all the like I said the
considerations that went into this
so the actual story here is that this
there's a lots of lots of acronyms here
but the a group of scientists this is
what the students will be playing the
role that they're a group of scientists
from this cetacean intelligence and
communication investigation lab and
they're undergoing training for an
upcoming voyage of discovery to a
peculiar and desolate area known as the
Caribbean trapezoid as far as I know
there's no way to in the Wolfram
language right now there's nothing no
fundamental thing that will draw a
Caribbean trapezoid but we'll be
extending that now a robotic sea turtle
named Ames artificially intelligent
multi-sensory signal and pattern
perceiver will accompany the ship
riff-raff on the exploratory mission I'd
originally thought about this idea of if
they were on onboard the ship they would
have like a ship computer to help them
with navigation figuring out you know
which way is the wind blowing and the
current going and where should we head
and read the bottom all that and then I
I started to realize how much more
interesting it would be to have apes be
embodied as a sea turtle
now I had to coming from the Caribbean
here Apes not used to the cold or
climate so I had to warm them up a
little bit but so this is this is the
idea of of our robotic sea turtle and
you can see we've we've been working on
a 3d design for Apes that that
ultimately what will part of what the
the researchers will have to learn how
to do is control Apes so that it can go
out and move around execute roll pitch
in yours but much more than that Ames is
because it's robotic will have the
capability of making sounds and having
lights the the very distinctive pattern
on the back of the sea turtle here as it
turns out if you just divide here and
here then you end up with 12
hexagonal or polygonal regions around
here and of course three hexagons right
in the middle so you'll see how we were
able to start making use of that for
aims to have a lot more capability here
let me see if I can scroll down a little
bit yeah so that's yet another picture
of riffraff here you'll notice that
there's some other things this is set up
actually right outside my office I
waited until the weekend and then
flooded the the hallway here so I could
do some real sea trials but the again
there's the K Cups being used out there
I've got a boom that's functioning as
the it's actually a boom stand
functioning as a mast and boom and
there's all kinds of repeated patterns
in here not only the piano keyboard
pattern but then the coloring that going
from red the yellow to green to cyan
that's blue to magenta so these themes
are all repeated you might not be able
to detect this this is actually a drum
hoop and with with lacing again with the
same coloring using parachute cord so
let's see I'll go ahead and get along
here so
sorry yeah so here's the the addition to
the story that the researchers from
sisal become aware that there's a troupe
of wild yet playful dolphins known as a
pod Calypso and they've taken refuge in
the Caribbean trapezoid but despite an
intense curiosity that strongly attracts
them towards harmonious syncopated
soon's rhythmic movement and colorful
geometric patterns they cautiously
remain distant and avoid direct
engagement with humans contrary to
typical tropical cetaceans so
consequently Ames will be sent as a
harbinger to convey a universally
meaningful and friendly intentions and
undergoing instruction on how to exhibit
expressive body language by the crew of
riffraff be able to then generate
enthralling sounds from the squad at
sisal and hopefully attract and engage
with with the dolphins here so this is
where they actually Ames came up with
the idea that could conduct clever and
catchy interactive song and dance
routines component from composed from
myriad mixes of music motion math and
media and draw a pod Calypso to observe
and eventually perform in synchrony
thereby producing Close Encounters of
the empty kind it's awfully quiet out
there you guys are just just believing
okay you weren't prepared for this I
suppose I thought the title was giving
enough of a hint but this was not going
to be completely as realistic as some of
the other talks perhaps you've been to
now I think an important part of
students education as I said all those
ease exercise entertainment and so forth
but enlightenment I think is a very
important part that's often overlooked
in education and that first quote from
Albert Einstein is something that I
think is really important has affected
me Apes came up with his own well he
we're not really sure I guess we should
just call it it but again this idea that
knowledge without kindness I think is is
really quite flat and dimensionless I
think we need to incorporate that more
and more Kurt Vonnegut is one of my
favorite science fiction writers if he's
not always considered a science fiction
writer but I certainly I'd probably
don't share too many things with him
other than the fact that when I do write
I do feel like an armless and legless
man with a crayon and there's math so
this this is where I've penned kind of
my own little bit of story that my
students in a class that I'm teaching
this semester haven't quite seen this
story yet I've been hinting to them that
now that we've passed midterm things are
going to get a little bit crazier but
more creative I'm expecting that that
many of these students are going to be
wanting to write their own version of a
story and I think that's a great part of
this idea of computational essay that
they can mix writing creativity we're
gonna see like music making dancing and
movement sports all these elements they
can bring in and kind of come up with
something that they can make their own
so you've got to be careful again make
their own so I'm not going to in fact
read all of this part here to you but
this will be posted if you can download
it and read it yourself and I think it
sort of lends itself to further
extension and maybe even making
something that's that's possibly more
believable but actually if if you've
read anything at all about dolphins and
what they do in Dolphin Research dolphin
communication and intelligence research
some of these things are not that
far-fetched actually a lot of
researchers you can go look at some TED
Talks there's a researcher who's been
working with someone from Georgia Tech
to design interfaces that would allow
divers to be able to communicate with
dolphins get them to play games
get them to understand certain types of
not only gestures and symbols but
dolphins themselves it's well-known that
even though there's much that's not
known about the communications dolphins
have their own signature whistles every
dolphin has a unique type of pattern
that it develops that it has and humans
have been able to get dolphins using
synthesized signature whistles they've
been able to get dolphins to sort of
adapt their convention like this
signature whistle means a ball or this
one means a piece of rope and when the
dolphin wants a toy like that they can
quickly pick up on if they make the
right signature whistle sound imitating
a real civic signature whistle of some
sort then they'll be able to get it so a
lot of these ideas were we're
incorporating into our experience here
as I said I the course that I'm teaching
this semester the students have been
working on going through the first well
we went through the first 16 chapters of
Steven Wolfram's elementary introduction
to the Wolfram language book and then
there now while I'm away this week
they're working on their own through the
the graphs and networks along with the
machine learning so but the next thing
after they took the midterm which was
pretty much just a recognition of basic
Wolfram language the next thing that I
had them do and this is what they're
working on while I'm gone is various
types of pattern recognition exercises
being able to take some wolfram code
Wolfen language code understand what it
does and then extend it to do something
more for example here's something that
we've been doing a lot of just
discussion of binary patterns and so
forth and so here's some code that
generates this and then I'd give them
something like this and say okay now you
figure out how to extend it like that
and I think I think this this works very
well to start it to get them away from
the fairly Elementary
useful exercises they go through in the
beginning and then get them into the
starting to be creative and invent their
own things so I know I don't have time
to go through all of these examples here
so I hope those of you that are
interested will take time to do it like
here's another example where they've
given given something that that already
does something sorry give them something
that already does some kind of a
function here and then give them
something else and ask them to combine
that with with the previous code up here
and then be able to produce something
that would that would do something like
this yeah and then lastly of course I'm
told that I'm not able to play any audio
for you all to hear it so that's
unfortunate but again if you if you go
to the if you download the the notebook
here you'll be able to to do a little
bit these exercises yourself if you want
eventually wanted them to be able to
develop the code that would generate a
pattern like this and you can see now
what with the what the actual potential
is for aims to have the colors and so
forth on here so when Ames is out
interacting with a pod Calypso there'll
be a song playing and there'll be lights
going on now what I imagine is I'm not
going to probably get real dolphins so
I'll probably have what I call dolphin
in Persona flyers in personification
this what am i calling it impersonators
these will be kids let's say that have
these dolphin puppets
with the accelerometers in them and
they'll be able to learn how to follow
amps and dance along with it and so I
think there's a lot of potential here
for developing this further the
following talk now coming right up is
again Ashwin who's going to show some
demos and talk about all the work that
he did to to develop it so anybody have
any questions